SETH LADD: OK, welcome
everyone.
Thanks very much for coming.
This is What's New with Dart:
Your First-Class Upgrade to
Web Development.
My name is Seth Ladd.
I'm a Developer Advocate
with the Dart team.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: And I'm
Justin Fagnani.
I'm an engineer on the
Dart team working
on tools and libraries.
And I also help internal
teams move to Dart.
SETH LADD: All right, real
quick, what is Dart?
Well, Dart is much more
than a language.
It's also a set of rich
libraries, very productive
tools, fast run-times like
a virtual machine.
But probably most importantly,
Dart compiles the JavaScript.
So you could write a Dart app,
compile it down to modern
JavaScript, and run
it across modern
browsers like this today.
We like to think of Dart
as a batteries
included package for you.
OK, so this is a real-life story
from a developer just
like you guys out there.
He works for a bank.
He has to write a
lot of web apps.
So he's telling me.
This is true.
He's saying, OK, the other day I
was asked to build a new web
app for my internal customers.
So hi, I want to build
a web app.
First off, you need to go get
require.js because you need
some sense of modularity.
He needed to get Backbone
because he needs some sense of
client-side infrastructure.
He needed to get Backbone
Marionette because, of course,
he needs some extra
functionality.
He needed to get jQuery
because every web
project uses jQuery.
Whether you like it or not,
somebody uses it.
He needed to get Modernizr
because he needed to do
feature detection.
He needed to get moment.js
because he needed to deal with
dates, parsing dates,
formatting dates.
He needed to then get dest
templates because he needed
some solution for client-side
templates.
He needed to get PhantomJS
because he needed some sense
of browser-based testing.
Then he needed to get Jasmine
because he needed to actually
write those tests.
Then when he's got this
teetering pile here, of course
then he finds out that every
one of these projects has a
completely different set
of formatted docs.
So you got to find those
and read those and
figure those out.
And then, he needed to finally
integrate this entire pile
here to make some semblance
of a working system.
An interesting thing here
though, is that not only do
you actually have to wire
it all together.
But some of these solutions
offer duplicate answers to the
same problem.
So you've got to
reconcile that.
So after he built this kind of
teetering pile here, quote, "I
just want to build web apps."
So then he found the Dart
project-- true story.
He was able to replace the
teetering pile with simply
just the Dart SDK and three
packages that he could just
download with our
package manager.
And quote, "Thanks to Dart,
things are consistent and
clear."
So this is a good example of a
real-life story of a small
team, a team that needs to
move fast, and their
experience using Dart.
But that's an external
small team.
Justin, how's our internal
teams doing?
JUSTIN FAGNANI: So like I
mentioned, I help internal
teams adopt Dart.
And at Google, we build
a few web apps.
And some of them
are quite big.
To give you an idea of how big
they are, our teams can be
from dozens to hundreds
of engineers.
And we can easily have millions
of lines of code.
And over the years, our
engineers have determined that
they need tools to help them
manage this complexity.
And basically, maintain their
sanity to be able to work with
such large amounts of
code in large teams.
So they've built tools like
GWT and Closure and Soy.
And these tools do different
things to help them guarantee
correctness and behavior
of the applications.
They introduce modularity
and structure, classes.
Maybe some type checking.
GWT introduces Java as
the source language.
And these tools have been very
successful in that they help
teams write these complex
apps and actually get
them out the door.
But they have some downsides.
In particular, all JavaScript
at Google is compiled.
And this means that we've
introduced a compiler into the
development workflow.
And that can significantly
slow things down.
With these large apps, the
compilers can take a long time
to run while you're trying
to develop your app.
So we've started moving
some teams to Dart.
And with Dart, we tried
to fix that problem.
SETH LADD: I want to point out
real quick that this is real
feedback from internal teams.
24 minutes, sometimes,
to see a change.
Can you imagine iterating at
24-minutes per change?
JUSTIN FAGNANI: I've
done that.
SETH LADD: Surely
we can better.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: Right.
So surely we could do better.
So what we've done with Dart
is we've tried to address
these issues.
To fix some of the problems
with the structure and the
semantics of the language, but
also not have the downsides.
So here we have a chart that
kind of shows some different
projects out there
that are compiled
to JavaScript projects.
So we have GWT and
Closure here.
I'm sure you guys have heard
of CoffeeScript.
And also, Microsoft has their
own compile to JS project
called TypeScript.
And we've kind of roughly said
whether or not they hurt and
help on these different
dimensions.
And we feel like Dart is finally
a solution that we
have that helps on
every dimension.
It actually improves the
development cycle, while also
giving teams the safety and
semantic improvements that
they require.
SETH LADD: One thing I want
to point out on this slide
actually, I think it's really
important to understand this
requires compilation
for development.
Notice how Dart does not require
compilation for your
very fast iteration development
cycles.
We'll see how we make that
possible in a little bit.
OK, cool.
So before we jump into all the
what's new across the whole
Dart platform--
and there's a lot-- we want to
give you a quick lightning
tour across the syntax,
semantics, and structure that
Dart offers so we can show you
a bunch of code samples
throughout the talk.
Let's start with the syntax.
First up, very familiar
classes,
semicolons, curly braces.
I think everyone can
read this code.
Dart's very terse.
We like to say it's
ceremony free.
Here's a good example here.
What do you always do in
constructors, but this.x
equals x, this.y equals
y, et cetera.
This is getting boring.
So instead you can say if the
constructor parameter name is
the same as the name of the
field, you can simply say
this.strength here
in this case.
Eliminates some of the ceremony
or boilerplate that
you typically have in
other languages.
Name constructors, one of my
favorite features here.
Obviously, methods you
can name pretty much
whatever you want.
But constructors, typically,
are always named
the name of the class.
That's a little bit
constraining, so Dart offers
name constructors.
Here, I can say new hug.bear
and set up a bear hug.
It's very clear.
I totally understand what I'm
creating when I use these name
constructors.
Dart has operator overriding.
Here's a good example of that.
Named, optional parameters,
another one of my favorite
features here.
So the curly braces here turn
on a couple things.
First, this becomes an
optional parameter.
So you may or may not--
or you can or cannot
pass a parameter there.
It's name that I understand
what this number is.
So hands.
And I get a default
value of one.
So again, features that normal
scripting languages have, Dart
has as well.
Some of my other favorite
features here-- fat arrow
syntax for your simple one-line
functions here.
This is just syntactic sugar
for curly brace return
expression curly brace.
Dart uses one-line functions
a lot, especially in inline
anonymous functions.
So they're really
useful there.
And finally, string
interpolation.
A very simple way to build up
strings based on variables or
expressions.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: OK, but Dart
isn't all just syntax
improvements.
Dart is its own language and
it has its own semantics.
And I'm sure some of you have
heard of the JavaScript wats
out there, or these surprising
moments.
Wat.
SETH LADD: Wat.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: In JavaScript.
Or the Java puzzlers.
So these are confusing
parts of the language
we're familiar with.
And we try to improve on that,
too, and turn our wats into
some kind of atomic rock
dinosaur thing.
But awesomeness in general.
SETH LADD: I want the
one on the right.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: Yes, me too.
It looks more fun.
SETH LADD: That one's scary.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: OK.
Some examples of semantic
improvements.
Just real quick, only
true is truthy.
So you don't have to guess what
values are going to be
true or false.
Basically, true is true, false
is false, and everything else
is what it is.
We got rid of undefined.
There's only null.
That fixes a lot of problems.
There's no type coercion with
equalities checks or operators
or other things like that.
So the language is more
predictable in a lot of ways.
Some other examples.
So in JavaScript, if you access
a property that isn't
available on an object, you
will get undefined.
So that can be a problem.
If you have a typo, you don't
necessarily know it.
You just get an undefined
value.
So in Dart, we changed this.
We fixed it.
And what do you think
happens here, Seth?
SETH LADD: Well, hopefully a
clear and consistent and
logical error.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: Well, that's
exactly right.
If you access a missing property
on an object in Dart,
you get a NoSuchMethodError
because Dart knows it doesn't
exist because it wasn't
declared.
Let's look at list access.
So here we have an empty list
and we're accessing the 99th
element of an empty list.
So we're way out of range.
What do you think happens
here, Seth?
SETH LADD: Hopefully
a clear and
consistent and logical error.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: Amazing.
You're right again.
Here, you get a range error,
like you would expect.
This has a number of benefits
to your program and the VM.
Next, let's talk about scope.
So JavaScript, as you might
know, has function scope.
And it hoists the function
declarations to
the top of the function.
So here we have two variables
with the same name "foo." One
of them is a top-level scope and
the other one is inside of
this block here, inside
the if statement.
So when we print foo here, how
do we know which one is going
to be printed?
Well, so we call this method
here and it's going to print
something, Seth.
What do you think it prints?
SETH LADD: Hopefully, due
to the logical static
[? analysis ?]
I can do with my own eyes
here, top-level.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: Seth
is a ringer.
Yes, it does print top-level.
So these things are less
confusing, less surprising and
better for development.
This also.
So we have lexically
scoped this.
This is bound to a
lexical scope.
You always know what this
is going to refer to.
In DOM programming, for example,
the "this" pointer of
an event handler actually refers
to the function that's
the event handler, not the
object that you're in when you
define that function.
And there's libraries that
try to fix this.
But in Dart, we've just gone
ahead and fixed it for you.
So in this case, this refers
to our instance of awesome
button and it calls
the right method.
And it's just very
unsurprising.
SETH LADD: OK, so that
was the syntax, a
little bit of the semantics.
Let's talk about
the structure.
Now, we've seen functions and
classes, and we'll see some of
these other features like
mixins in a little bit.
So let's talk about libraries.
Dart has a really nice way to
bunch up your code into
reusable chunks we
call libraries.
Here's an example here.
This is a single file.
You simply declare that a file
is a library using library
games here in this case.
You can import other
libraries.
Dart:math comes from
the Dart SDK.
players.dart is another Dart
file, so we can pull in other
files as libraries as well.
And a feature I really like is
you can put, say, multiple
classes, top-level functions
all in the same file.
So it gives you a very flexible
way to organize not
only just where you want
to put your classes and
functions, but also how you want
to structure them on the
file system.
But everything falls
inside a library.
You can then import them
and reuse them.
OK, that was a lightning tour.
Let's look at some
of what's new.
We'll start with the language.
All right, here's a common thing
that you always do, say,
working with a DOM.
You want to create a new button
and set up the state of
that button--
ID, text, classes,
click handlers.
Well, in this particular
case, I've
repeated button six times.
That's a lot.
Well, taking a cue from
Smalltalk, we've introduced
method cascades.
And in this example here, I've
eliminate the repetition of
the variable button.
See the double dots here?
All of these expressions are
applied to this very first
expression here new
ButtonElement.
I've eliminated most of the
occurrences of button here.
I like this for builder
type APIs.
It makes it just more
clear and concise.
But we can do a little bit
better, because all of these
different cascades roll up to
this first expression here.
I can actually eliminate
the need to
introduce a new variable.
So here you can see I can add
this new button element to the
children of this parent element
and initialize its
state all within the
same call here.
This is really--
JUSTIN FAGNANI: One great thing
about this is that it
turns every API into
a builder API.
So you don't have to
preemptively return this from
all your methods in order
to have a fluent API.
In Dart, every API becomes
fluent and it's universal
across the board
and consistent.
OK.
So let's talk about another
great new language feature
called mixins.
So mixin is something that
languages, like Newspeak and
Smalltalk have, and it's a way
to share code without using
inheritance.
You might be familiar with the
maxim, composition over
inheritance.
And the idea is that there's
problems if you try to share
code exclusively through
inheritance.
You can only have
one super-class.
So it might not be a class you
actually want to extend.
So in the last year, Dart's
added mixins.
And let's take our hug example
from before and let's say we
want to save it to a database.
A typical solution to this is
you extend some kind of
persistable base class.
But that has a lot
of problems.
You might want to extend some
other class, actually.
So what you're interested in
here is the behavior, not
necessarily the inheritance
hierarchy.
Hug is not actually
a persistable.
It has the persistable
behavior.
So you don't want to pollute
your inheritance tree.
Instead, what you want to do
is just add this behavior.
You want to compose it or slide
it in from the side--
the persistable behavior.
So what does this look like?
Well, up top here we have our
abstract class persistable.
And in save and load, we defined
the behavior we want,
the implementations in the
dot, dot, dots there.
And we require that classes
that implement persistable
implement this toJson method.
Once they do that, save and load
can use that method in
order to implement
their behavior.
So down here in our hug class,
we're going to use the brand
new keyboard with to say that we
want to mix in the behavior
from persistable into
our hug class.
And then you'll notice that we
define that toJson class,
which is used by the
other methods.
And in the bottom here, you can
see that we call the save
method that's been
added to hug.
It's not inheritance and it
behaves as you would expect.
So this is a great way to
compose classes together.
You also notice that persistable
is just a class.
We don't have a mixin keyword.
So that's just a few
restrictions.
If your class extends object
and it doesn't have a
constructor, then you can
use it as a mixin.
And some of these restrictions
might go away over time.
Oh, we had animations.
All right.
SETH LADD: Another new
feature are metadata.
Here's a good example.
You can use metadata with the
at symbol here, @deprecated.
And that gives really good
feedback to, say, tools.
In this case, the Dart Editor,
he can look at @deprecated,
and then visually indicate the
functions or methods that are
deprecated.
The nice thing about metadata
in Dart though, is you can
define your own metadata.
Here's a good example of an
in-progress feature we're
working on, lazy load libraries,
that uses const
objects as metadata
annotations.
Let's try to walk through
some of this code.
So first we're going to declare
that the library
itself is deferred.
We're creating a const
object, const lazy.
We can then use that lazy
const object to mark the
import as lazy as shown here.
Then, we can call load on that
lazy const object, the
deferred library, and use a
Future to wait for that
library to finish loading.
Then, we can use the features
and functionality from that
library inside of the future.
Now, our tools can read these
metadata annotations here and
say, take in Dart applications
spread across multiple files.
Pipe them through dart2js,
which can look for these
metadata annotations and spit
out a single JavaScript file
for the bulk of the app.
And then, another JavaScript
file for
that lazy loaded library.
This is a great deployment time
tool for you to choose
how and when you want to load in
the different components of
your application.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: OK, so that's
what's new in the language.
Let's talk next about
the libraries.
There's been a lot of great
developments in the last year.
First, let's talk about the
number one question that we
get asked with Dart
is, can I use
existing JavaScript libraries?
Can I integrate with JavaScript
in some way?
And the answer is yes.
We do this through our
JavaScript interop package.
Now, Dart can exist in two
different worlds, really.
We have this Dart to JS world,
where everything is compiled
to JavaScript.
And also, in Dartium, we have
a world where there's two
different VMs.
And so you don't always have
direct access to the objects.
So the way JavaScript interop
works is that
we use proxy objects.
And these proxy objects
represent an object that's in
the other environment.
And the calls are forwarded,
data is
serialized as necessary.
So let's show an example.
So here we're using the JS
package with the prefix js.
We have code up top in Dart and
down below in JavaScript.
And we're going to use an
imaginary charts API.
You can see that the code looks
very, very similar.
In the first line, here we're
just stashing a reference to
the API object.
In the second line, we need
to create some data.
Because our charts API is a
JavaScript API and we need the
data to be a JavaScript array,
we simply pass a Dart array to
this function that creates a
JavaScript array out of it.
And then in the third line
here, we want to
create a new chart.
The way you do this from the
Dart world is you say, I want
to create a new proxy.
And you tell it what constructor
and what
arguments to use.
A little bit different,
but looks very
similar to the line below.
And then finally, chart
is now a proxy to
a JavaScript object.
And now you can interact with
it in a way that looks very
much like any other
Dart object.
And in fact, looks identical
to the JavaScript below.
So with a JS interop package,
you can use JavaScript APIs.
This is very important for
existing applications.
SETH LADD: Another new library
we've been working on over the
past year is our Mirror-based
reflection library.
With mirror-based reflection,
you can do source code and
run-time reflection.
That is, you can load up a bunch
of source code and use
mirrors to ask questions
about it.
You can also, at run-time, ask
questions about the structure
of your app.
You can use mirrors to reflect
on both classes and instances.
And you can introspect, say what
fields do you have, what
construction do you have, and
invoke methods on those
objects dynamically.
How might we use this?
Well, here's an example of
creating a logging proxy.
Say I have some client code that
wants to call Hello on
some object, but I wanted to go
through a proxy that logs
all these calls.
So it's going to hit
proxy first.
He's going to print out some
sort of logging statement.
Then he's going to delegate
the actual Hello call back
down to the true delegate
object.
Let's see how we do this with
mirrors and reflection.
So first up, import the
Dart mirrors library.
It comes to you from
the Dart SDK.
Next, use the top-level function
reflect to reflect on
the delegate object and get
back an instance mirror.
Next, now remember if you call
a getter or function on an
object and that doesn't
exist, you'll get a
noSuchMethodError.
It's Nice clear, and concise.
You can actually implement
noSuchMethod here and capture
those calls and do something
dynamic and
interesting with it.
In this case, we're going to do
that to capture all calls
going through our
logging proxy.
Before we actually delegate,
let's go ahead and
log that call out.
We'll just print it
out very easily.
And then, using that instance
mirror itself, we can delegate
the original call that came in
from noSuchMethod and pipe it
into the actual delegate
itself.
This is a really nice way to
deal with run-time dynamic
programs using noSuchMethod
and mirrors.
Here's the example.
We're going to create a login
proxy wrap greeter.
We're going to call the Hello
method on what we
think is the greeter.
But of course, it's going
through logging proxy.
Two things will be
printed out.
First, the symbol Hello
was called.
That comes from the
logging proxy.
And then, Hello that comes from
the greeter because we
delegated that call back
down to the delegate.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: All right, let's
talk about something
that's very important for web
programming, which is
asynchronous APIs
and asynchronous
programming in Dart.
So Dart's had some facilities
for asynchronous programming
and they've been greatly
expanded in the
new Dart Async library.
First of all, why is async
programming so important?
Why is it such a big
deal for Dart?
Well, the web is full of
asynchronous APIs.
These are the APIs that when
you invoke them, they don't
block your program and they
go do some work in the
background.
Or maybe they wait for some
event to happen and they need
to notify your program
when they're done,
so they take a callback.
And when they've loaded some
data or a user clicks on a
button or something, the
callback is invoked.
If you need to perform some data
after that, then you need
to call another--
perform another asynchronous
operation after that, you need
to call another API in the
callback and then register
another callback.
You end up with these nested
callbacks, which leads us to
what is known as
callback hell.
Well, with Dart, we've tried
to add features to the
libraries that make your life
easier and lead you from
callback hell to callback
nirvana, or
callback tropical beach.
SETH LADD: Beautiful beach.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: Yeah.
And we do this with futures
and streams.
So first, let's take
a look at futures.
So a future is a promise that
there will be some value
delivered to you at some
time in the future.
In fact, in JavaScript
libraries, the concept is
often called promises.
So first, let's look at a
callback example here.
DoStuff is an asynchronous
method.
It takes as a first argument a
callback that will be invoked
when it's done.
And as its second optional
method, an error handler.
So this is what a callback-based
API would look
like in Dart.
And as you can see, even with
a simple one-level deep no
nesting, it's already looking
a little complicated.
Well, with futures, what you
do is instead of taking a
callback, you return a future.
And this future object has
a very consistent way of
registering the callback
in the error handler.
All futures are the
same class.
They all do this the same way.
And you can see it already
looks a little cleaner.
But because futures chain, they
return themselves, you
can make this look
even simpler.
You don't actually have to store
the future in a value.
And in fact, in Dart,
you often see code
that looks like this.
You call an asynchronous
method.
You register a handler and
you register a callback.
And it looks very sequential.
SETH LADD: We should point out
here that handle and handle
errors themselves
are functions.
So we can pass in a function
right into these callbacks
without dealing with a whole
one-line or multiple line,
like what you see on the left.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: Exactly.
All right, now let's look at
something where we have more
than one level of nesting.
So here's an imaginary cat
service, because we all know
the internet basically exists
for trading cat pictures.
So the first step we do here
is we get some cat data.
And once we get the cat
data, we're going to
want to go get a picture.
And then once we have the
picture, we're going to want
to rotate it and some work.
These are all asynchronous
calls.
And finally, four levels deep,
we do the work we wanted to.
And you can already see that the
control flow here is hard
to follow because it's based on
the nesting and where the
arguments are.
But it gets even worse.
Now imagine you want to
do error handling.
And if these methods each take
an error handler, than the
error handlers get a little bit
separated from the callbacks.
And if there's actually real
work being done in these, if
they're not just one-liners,
this becomes very
complicated to follow.
But if you imagine the same
example with futures, it
becomes much simpler.
With futures, the errors are
propagated through them and
you can chain them
with different
asynchronous calls in a row.
And you can make that same
nested callback structure look
like a sequence of events.
So this is where futures start
to show some big advantages in
terms of clarity of the code.
SETH LADD: When you say the
error is propagated-- so an
error or exception can
happen at any one of
these calls to then.
It will bubble down to
that one catch error.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: Exactly.
You don't have to register
multiple error handlers.
It's almost like a try catch
block, but asynchronously.
OK, so that's not all, right?
So futures are nice and
consistent and they clean up
the code structure
a little bit.
But futures also compose.
Future is like our first-class
concept of, there will be a
value in the future.
And you can write utilities
that deal in futures.
And one of the most basic
utilities is just waiting for
things to happen in parallel.
So future has a static method on
it called wait, which takes
a list of other futures.
It waits for them all to
complete and returns a new
future when it's done.
And so this is a very easy way
to wait for parallel items.
You can imagine in JavaScript,
you usually have to keep some
kind of counter of how many
callbacks have finished, and
update them, and error handling
becomes difficult.
Well, here it's all
done for you.
You just give it a
list of futures.
Here we're getting two
pictures and we
want to blend them.
And we still have an error
handler down at the bottom.
So we work with both pictures.
I'll go back.
And notice that the error
handler will work on the
future that are happening
in parallel and
every subsequent operation.
OK, so futures have been around
for a little while, but
what's really new in
Dart is streams.
So futures only fire once.
But you also have to worry about
repeating events, things
like user interaction with
the UI and I/O. So
streams are the new thing.
And they are the repeating
analog to future.
And in the Dart libraries,
because we get to start fresh,
nearly all repeating events
in Dart are streams.
You should see very, very, if
any, little callback-based
APIs anymore.
SETH LADD: I think that's
an excellent point.
With futures and streams, we
bake them across the APIs and
libraries we've built.
So everything from, say, opening
files to XML HTTP
request, to get user media, to
the file I/O, the directories.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: All your
basic DOM events.
SETH LADD: All this now is
futures and streams.
And you get that because we bake
it into the SDK for you.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: And because we
got to start fresh with the
libraries, too.
So let's take a look
at an example.
Here, we're going to look at
the documentation for the
element class.
This is the base class for
all the HTML elements.
And you can see that there's
this line here that says
onKeyPress is a property
that's a
stream of keyboard events.
So what does that mean?
It means that we can do a query
here for a text area.
And we can access this
onKeyPress property and call
listen, which is very much
like then on a future.
The function given to listen
will be invoked every time
that there's a keypress
event and it will
be given that event.
So here we simply turn our key
press event into a string and
print it out.
So this'll print char equals
wherever we happen to type.
But streams do a lot more.
They have a very,
very rich API.
You can filter the events.
You can transform them.
You can turn streams into
futures by getting the first
or last element in a stream.
So here's an example where
we want to get
our keypress event.
And let's say we only care about
events that are actually
keys on the keyboard that
you can type and read.
So you might want to want these
to get rid of control
characters and things.
So here, we can just
filter the stream.
And we use some range filter
to say these are our valid
characters.
And this returns a new stream,
where we can call listen or
more transformation
methods on.
And next we're going
to call map.
And what map does is it takes
every element, every event in
the stream and it turns it into
some new kind of event
and creates a new stream
out of that.
So here we're going to
map and turn our
keyboard events into strings.
Finally, let's say we're only
concerned with the very first
keypress in our text
area here.
So we can call first on the
stream and that returns us a
future now, which returns
a value when that
key is first pressed.
And then we call then
like we did before.
And we can print out
that the first
character is that character.
And you can see that this
reads really nice.
And because streams are so
common across the libraries,
you'll be able to see and
recognize these patterns
across Dart code bases.
Finally, this is a relatively
short talk.
So we don't have enough time,
nearly enough time to go to
HTML and web components.
There is a talk later at 3:30
PM with Emily and Seth.
And they're going to go deep
into the new developments in
HTML and web components and how
you develop rich complex
UIs in Dart.
A lot of changes in the last
year is that we've Dartified
the HTML library.
It follows Dart idioms, uses
Dart collections, and gives
you some jQuery-like
functionality.
We also have Web UI, which
is our custom elements
implementation.
We've done things like gotten
rid of vendor prefixes so you
can just use one method call.
So that's at 3:30
PM in this room.
Yeah.
SETH LADD: OK, cool.
Let's look at what's new
across the tools
and ecosystem here.
Well, one thing that's really
important to point-- and we
alluded to do this earlier--
is that the development cycle in
Dart is very, very fast and
very quick and iterative.
This is important for web
developers who are used to
simply making a change
and hitting
Reload in their browser.
They want to see that
change immediately.
They don't want to be slowed
down by any sort of compile
time process during the bulk
of their development.
So I'm happy to say that
with Dartium--
it's a special build of Chromium
with the Dart Virtual
Machine embedded inside--
we can deliver those very fast,
no compiles required,
edit/reload cycles.
So typically the flow will
look something like this.
The feature
[? bugging section ?]
throughout the bulk of the
development, you're simply
writing code, hitting
Reload in Dartium.
Boom, you see the change
right away.
Only right at the very end--
and this is what we've been
told by real users of Dart.
Only at the very end will they
introduce dart2js, compile
their application into
JavaScript, and test on all of
the browsers.
So this is really,
really nice.
We've also been working
on a standalone
editor called Dart Editor.
This is built from the ground
up, built on the Eclipse
platform, to give you features
and functionalities you're
used to when you develop
code and apps on
all the other platforms.
Things like refactoring.
Things like jump to definition,
inline types, a
nice problems view.
The list goes on and on.
This is the kind of productive
developments experience that
you like when you deal with code
as you grow from 1 to 10,
to 1,000 to, to, say, 500 or a
million lines of code, which
is not unheard of when you build
the kind of apps users
are demanding.
But if Eclipse is in your bag,
that's OK, because we've also
got plug-ins for VIM.
An actual plug-in for Eclipse
as opposed to Dart Editor,
which is a standalone editor.
Plug-ins for Sublime.
And our friends IntelliJ
and WebStorm--
they're actually up there in
the Chrome booth-- can show
off their Dart plug-in
as well.
So hopefully we've got a choice
for you across whatever
editor you are working with.
Now, we'd love to show a demo of
this, but we have something
really new and exciting to
show you guys in terms of
editing Dart.
We're happy to announce the
relaunch of try.dartlang.org
that our team's been
working on.
We've taken the dart2js
compiler, compiled it with
itself into JavaScript, put it
in a browser, and given you
the ability to write Dart code
and see it live without having
to install anything.
So let's see.
Let's take a look.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: All right.
Let's check it out.
OK, so this is try.dartlang.org.
As Seth mentioned, this is
using dart2js, which has
compiled itself to be able
to run in the browser.
So this is the same compiler
that the editor and the
command line applications use.
So here we have a simple
little text editor.
Notice we have some syntax
highlighting happening here
because of dart2js.
We're going to change this
to Hello Google I/O.
And notice it's compiling
on the fly.
And there we go.
We see the output.
Also notice that this is
running in Firefox.
So it's important to note how
critical dart2js is to the
deployment step here, and how
much it enables Dart to run on
all of the modern web.
SETH LADD: Nice improvements
also is this works offline.
This works on your iPad.
And you can also edit
HTML apps as well.
So very nicely way for you to
try Dart, and then go pick an
editing experience that
works for you.
OK, what else in tools
and ecosystem?
Well, we have a nice unit
test library that
comes out of the box.
We also have a mock library
that comes out of the box.
Here's a quick code sample
here at the top
for our unit test.
It looks familiar and I think
a lot of other unit test
frameworks you might
have seen before.
Also, happy to announce that
we a headless version of
Chromium we call dump
render tree.
But this allows you to run
HTML-based Dart tests in a
headless browser.
And say, then take that and
wire it into continuous
integration services, like
Drone.io, who have native
support for Dart and this
headless Chrome.
So you can check in your code
into Bitpocket or GitHub, fire
off a change which Drone.io
picks up, runs all of your
tests from the command line,
runs all of your HTML tests or
web tests in this headless
Chrome and reports back to you
how everything's working.
So you now start to see this
nice chain for really rich
end-to-end development
experience.
Also, been working on a
package manager, we
affectionately call
Pub because you
play darts in a pub.
And with Pub, you can download
packages, manage the
dependencies and the updates,
publish your own packages to
Pub, and browse around
pub.dartlang.org, which is our
hosting service, where there's
already over 200 packages out
there ranging everything from
database drivers, to MVC
frameworks, to encryption, to
parsers, game libraries, the
list goes on and on and on.
It's very easy for you guys to
publish your own packages into
Pub as well.
Pub works with our central
hosting service here.
[? Git, ?]
local file system.
Very easy for you to reuse
and send out and share
functionalities across
Dart apps.
We're also really happy to
announce that the Flash Pro,
the really rich animation
engine, game engine, or game
editing tool from Adobe now can
export your animations and
games to Dart.
You can see a demo of this
up at our booth up
in the Chrome area.
So real quickly, you
don't have to
write any action script.
You can use the really rich
editing experience of the
stage and the timeline and all
the asset managements of Flash
Pro and go through their toolkit
here and export that
all out to Dart code
and HTML5 APIs.
Which means you can use their
really slick tools here, And
then deploy that across the
modern web without any
plug-ins at all.
So if you guys are interested
in this, come
check this out upstairs.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: OK, next let's
talk about things that are
very important to
web developers--
size and speed, or
performance.
So the web has gone on a
continuous evolution path
since it started.
And one of the things that's
happened with JavaScript is
that it initially enabled the
very first client-side apps.
And JavaScript wasn't that
fast, but then JavaScript
became faster.
With the advent of fast VMs
like V8, applications that
started rivaling desktop
applications were
now suddenly possible.
And the applications grew
to use this performance.
So as all the VMs out there
got faster and faster, the
applications took advantage of
that and became more complex.
So we see this continual
advancement and
power-hungriness of
applications.
So we don't see that ending.
Performance is still
important.
Another reason why performance
really, really matters is
because of mobile.
Now, on your laptop you have a
fairly large battery, or on
your desktop you're plugged
into the wall.
But on your phone or your
tablet, you actually don't
have that large of a battery.
If you last a day, that
might be a good day.
And performance directly
impacts that.
The faster your application is,
the less CPU it's using,
that means the less battery
it's using.
Even a 10% increase in battery
life is a significant
improvement.
So this really matters.
And yeah, so what we like to say
is that every performance
improvement is a battery
improvement.
So first let's talk about
dart2js here in
terms of our tools.
So as we said, the dart2js is
responsible for compiling Dart
to JavaScript.
Quickly, the way this works
is that we pull in your
application and all the
libraries it imports.
We run it through all the
optimizations and compilation
steps that dart2js does to
minify your application.
And then, we output a JavaScript
file, the compiled
version of your app.
SETH LADD: We also output a
source map to enable really
easy debugging, which maps the
original Dart code to the
compiled JavaScript code.
And your Chrome DevTools can
read all that, so when set a
break point in your Chrome
DevTools, it's actually
setting a breakpoint from the
Dart code and mapping to the
Javascript code.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: Which also
works in browsers like
Firefox, and I believe, IE.
OK, so let's look at some of the
generated JavaScript, so
you can see a little bit about
what the compiler is doing.
So here's a very
simple example.
We have a Dart program that's
using the HTML library and it
Defines a simple class, person,
and then it uses that
class in some simple way
in the main method.
So here's a JavaScript output
that the dart2js has produced.
And you can see that it actually
is very readable and
kind of corresponds logically
to the Dart source code.
In fact, in this case, there's
like a one-to-one
correspondence between the lines
of Dart and the lines of
JavaScript.
But like we mentioned, Dart
has minification.
And it has tree shaking, which
is dead code elimination.
So it's important to produce the
smallest application sizes
as possible.
So when you turn minification
on, you can see that as part
of the compilation process, we
renamed variables and inline
functions and do interesting
things here to give you the
most compact JavaScript
possible.
SETH LADD: So Justin mentioned
tree shaking.
Well, what's tree shaking?
So if you look at the marketing
material, pretty
much every JavaScript library
out there, the first and
foremost thing they tell
you is how small it is.
Instead, I, as a developer, care
how good it is and how it
can help me.
Well, you shouldn't have to
worry about how small the
libraries are.
You should let the tools
handle that kind
of stuff for you.
Here's an example here.
Here's an application.
You've written the stuff on your
left here and it pulls in
a library-- the library
in the yellow.
And one of your functions calls
just one function from
the yellow library.
And there's no reason why you
should have to pull in all
that baggage if you can
determine only the functions
or the features that you
actually need in your app.
Well, dart2js performs a
tree-shaking functionality,
which takes all the
dependencies, all the imports,
all the libraries and can look
at the program and say, OK,
these are the bits you actually
use and produce just
the code that is required
to run your app.
Notice how you don't have these
leaf nodes that you
never actually call.
This is another reason why
dart2js can produce smaller,
faster output for you.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: Let's
talk about the
performance of the Dart VM.
So if you saw Lars and Casper's
talk, they went into
great detail about why
the VM is faster.
But real quickly, Dart has more
explicit and static and
declarative structure.
This allows the VM to be
braver and make smarter
optimizations.
And it allows the VM
to be simpler.
We have real arrays
and real classes.
You can invoke a method without
having to call the
prototype chain to see if the
method has changed at all.
So these things allow the VM
to be much faster already.
And in addition to that, we're
able to use more of your CPU.
So we've added SIMD extensions,
recently, to Dart.
If you look at a modern CPU, a
significant portion of the die
is dedicated to these vector
processors, these SIMD
processors.
This is an ARM CPU and you can
see that almost a third of the
CPU is dedicated to the neon
and vector operations.
SETH LADD: Yeah, traditional web
programming today can not
unlock the full capabilities
of your CPU.
And that's a real shame.
And so the Dart VM says, yeah,
let's give you this power.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: So how does
that performance actually
manifest itself?
Well, we have a few benchmarks
that we've been publishing.
And you can see the blue bar
here is the Dart VM.
And yes, higher is better.
And so you can see on these
performance benchmarks here
that the VM has been beating
handwritten JavaScript.
And in fact, on the array
tracing example, it's almost
two times as fast.
And if you notice over here on
the left, on the Delta Blue
benchmark, there are cases
where dart2js actually
produces faster code than
handwritten JavaScript because
of the optimizations
it's able to make.
So here in Delta Blue, dart2js
is a little bit faster than
JavaScript.
SETH LADD: We should point out
that Dart is not even yet a
1.0 production release and we're
still doing pretty good.
But we have more work to go.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: I think V8 has a
four or five-year head start
on the Dart VM.
OK, now, Seth.
SETH LADD: Sure.
Let's talk about this one.
So the nice thing is these
charts here are all running on
this beefy MacBook Pro.
This guy's got like 87 cores
and 52 gigs of RAM.
So of course, these numbers
are going to look really
impressive.
But does it translate down to
mobile, which is what we're
all going to be developing
by this time next year?
So happy to say that yes, the
same kind of performance
characteristics when you use
the Dart VM as opposed to
handwritten code does
translate over.
So this is running on Chrome for
Android with the Dart VM
embedded inside on
an x86 phone.
You can see here the yellow
is handwritten JavaScript.
The middle guy is
just Dart VM.
And then the big tall blue bar
is Dart VM having ported the
NBody simulation over to use
the SIMD instructions.
So every performance matters
on mobile phones.
As Justin said, it's all
about battery there.
So you'll see the same
gains, even on the
little devices here.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: This basically
covers what we have for you
for new stuff, but there's
so much more.
There's a lot of things we
didn't get to cover.
SETH LADD: We asked for the
three-hour slot and they
didn't give it to us.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: Yeah,
the keynote.
We could have filled
So we have an entire server-side
story with Dart.
It's very similar to Node and
we have an I/O library.
As Seth mentioned
earlier, we have
extensive testing libraries.
We also have a concurrency and
safety story in isolates that
we didn't get to cover.
And a lot more stuff.
So you should really find
out more about Dart.
SETH LADD: How do you find
out more about it?
Well, many different ways
for you to try out Dart.
Download the Dart SDK and the
Dart Editor from dartlang.org.
We're active on Google+ and
Twitter, et cetera.
We're also on GitHub as well.
So we've received many patches
from the community in
[? poll requests. ?]
We have external committers
as well.
We're active on Stack
Overflow.
And it's important to
understand, Dart is an open
source project.
BSD license, very permissive.
And so it's easy for you guys
to get involved in any
different way that works
for you guys.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: We've broken
up a lot of the smaller
projects into their own
repositories on GitHub.
And we've had a lot of external
contributors come in
that way because it's very
easy to get started.
SETH LADD: Lots more about Dart
here at I/O. Later today,
the Dart HTML talk.
Definitely check that out.
We have a Code lab on Friday.
So if you want to get your hands
dirty here working with
all the latest and greatest,
join us on Friday.
We'll be at office
hours as well.
And the demo booth, you
can see a lot of
this stuff in action.
So to sum it up, what's
the main takeaway?
Well, Dart-- we've got a
stable language now.
We have stable core libraries.
Dart compiles a JavaScript and
runs across modern browsers.
And it's really been an
involved platform now.
We've been out for, what?
Almost two years, one
and a half years?
We've gotten tons of feedback
from external developers,
internal customers, external
customers.
They've been telling
us what they like,
what they don't like.
We've put that all in.
And so what you see today is
a nice evolved platform.
And Google is committed
to Dart.
We have internal high-priority
projects inside using Dart.
And we're going to see this,
so that you can make it--
Dart is ready for your app.
That's the main point here.
Hopefully you liked
what you saw.
And we'll be around to answer a
lot of your questions here.
I think we can probably take
one or two questions.
But we'll be up at
the office hours
immediately after this talk.
And we'd love to hear what
you guys are building.
So with that, we're all set.
JUSTIN FAGNANI: Thanks.
SETH LADD: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SETH LADD: We could take
a question or two
if anyone has any.
OK, cool.
AUDIENCE: Do you think we'll
see Dart on App Engine?
SETH LADD: I would personally
love to see that happen.
There's a bug in the issue
tracker for App Engine.
Go ahead and star that
and let them know.
OK.
Thanks.
We'll be around here.
Thank you.